[Música]
hoy en el debate de France 24 vamos a
dejar de lado los temas de la coyuntura
internacional los temas más mainstream
que cubren los diferentes medios de
comunicación y vamos a poner la lupa en
una crisis que persiste y es la atención
en la región de nagorno caravag una
región que es habitada por personas de
mayoría Armenia pero que es reclamada
por hacer bailán veamos entonces Cuáles
son los hechos recientes de este
conflicto el pasado 12 de diciembre un
grupo de activistas medioambientales de
origen azerbaiyano bloquearon la vía que
atraviesa el corredor de la china que es
la única vía terrestre que une a nagorno
caravag con la República de Armenia y
con el resto del mundo ese fue el día
del inicio oficial de este bloqueo que
ya cumple un mes de estar cerrado este
corredor esto dejó entonces a 120.000
personas encerradas en la región de
nagorno caravag el bloqueo pues no
permite la entrada ni de medicinas ni de
alimentos y a cuentagotas dejan pasar a
algunas personas que deben tratamientos
médicos de urgencia en la República de
Armenia también por ejemplo la
electricidad y el servicio de internet
son cortados por azerbaiyán en
diferentes horas del día en los
diferentes sectores de esa región
recordemos que allí están en pleno
invierno y también recordemos que el
servicio de internet pues es la única
ventana que tienen los habitantes de
esta región para comunicarse con el
resto del mundo azerbaiyán justifica la
presencia de estos activistas que dieron
paso a las tropas del ejército de
azerbaiyán pero intentan completamente
desentenderse de la situación
la información sobre el bloqueo total de
carreteras y el bloqueo de esta región
por parte de azerbaiyán circula
ampliamente
en primer lugar quiero señalar que esta
información no corresponde a la realidad
muchos hechos pueden contradecirla
fácilmente
los manifestantes Están en contra del
saqueo de las fuentes naturales de
azerbaiyán Están en contra del
terrorismo ecológico
al mismo tiempo no tiene ninguna
intención de impedir el paso de carga y
suministros de mercancías vehículos o
civiles también hay mucha evidencia de
que durante todos esos días las
ambulancias los vehículos del comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja y los
convoyes de las fuerzas de paz pasaron
fácilmente en ambas direcciones
esta zona por ser un territorio en
disputa y donde también hay un estado
independiente autoproclamado y sin
reconocimiento que es la República de
arthash es una zona que está custodiada
por las tropas de paz del ejército ruso
un país que oficia como mediador en este
conflicto Rusia dijo que el 26 de
diciembre habilitaría el paso por el
corredor una promesa que todavía no se
ha materializado
ningún acuerdo especialmente un acuerdo
que duró más de una década se ejecuta el
100% y se ejecuta de inmediato
siempre cada parte del acuerdo sobre el
alto el fuego o la implementación de
medidas prácticas para estabilizar la
situación en terreno viola el acuerdo de
una manera u otra
normalmente las fuerzas de pase ocupan
de esas violaciones estas disposiciones
están incluidas en el acuerdo sobre
karaba las fuerzas de paz rusas están
trabajando allí
la República de Armenia le reclama a
Rusia justamente su falta de compromiso
parece que Rusia está un poco más
enfocada en la guerra en Ucrania la
situación ya es alarmante pero de
prolongarse podría desencadenar una
crisis humanitaria en el mediano plazo
sin embargo el ministro de estado de
Rubén Berta dijo que la situación es
complicada pero que Comida hay para los
habitantes y que no se van a morir de
hambre por lo menos por ahora
no solo influye en nuestra vida diaria
en nuestra medicina o en situaciones de
emergencia también influyen toda la
economía
estamos en invierno y hace bastante frío
en general definitivamente Crea una gran
presión psicológica para la población
no nos moriremos de hambre por la comida
porque hay suficiente
pero definitivamente algunos de los
productos no los podemos obtener en
nuestro mercado interno
sí tendremos algunos problemas con
algunos productos pero en general no
será una mala situación la gente no se
morirá de hambre
bueno tienen ustedes la mirada de Los
tres actores importantes de este
conflicto en el sur del cáucaso Qué ha
hecho entonces la comunidad
internacional para evitar esta escalada
está azerbaiyán intentando provocar un
desplazamiento de los astrajíes o
carabajíes está tratando de desarrollar
allí una limpieza étnica porque la Unión
Europea guarda silencio porque le compra
gasa azerbaiyán en medio de esta
situación Qué papel juegan países claves
como Rusia que ya veíamos una de las
aristas de cómo están manejando la
situación Estados Unidos donde hay una
enorme comunidad de ciudadanos armenios
y Turquía que es el gran Aliado de
azerbaiyán qué solución puede haber Por
qué el conflicto en agorno caravag está
dejado en el olvido Pues aquí en France
24 no lo vamos a dejar de lado y lo
vamos a poner otra vez sobre la mesa
para debatirlo aquí en nuestro programa
para analizar el sistema hemos invitado
a Ignacio Montes de Oca él es periodista
y escritor también está con nosotros
Fernando abaquián él es analista
internacional y analista de temas del
espacio post soviético nuestros
televidentes ustedes también lo saben
son parte de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el debate_f24
arroba santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 no
olviden también que todos los contenidos
de este programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast en Spotify y en deezer y
también en TuneIn
quiero hacer la advertencia que la
producción de invitados de este programa
intentó contactar a alguien de el
gobierno de azerbaiyán para ser parte de
esta mesa de debate para conocer
precisamente los dos lados de esta
moneda las dos caras de esta moneda de
este conflicto para entender la posición
de azerbaiyán Y fue imposible tener en
el estudio de France 24 en conexión
remota alguien oficial del gobierno de
azerbaiyán para que diera su punto de
vista Pues muy bien Vamos a comenzar
Entonces el programa haciendo un
análisis de lo que está sucediendo allí
le pregunto entonces a Ignacio primero
dándole la bienvenida Gracias por estar
con nosotros Ignacio y quiero conocer
entonces su perspectiva de lo que está
sucediendo allí de este mes de cierre de
este importante corredor vital para la
región de nagorno carava cuál es su
análisis
Gracias por Antes que nada y voy a voy a
presentar el punto de vista aserí
también para poder nutrear la audiencia
con con algunos puntos de vista
alternativos O sea que que los azerías
nos hacen presentes
la situación es grave quizás Estamos muy
ocupados con Ucrania Pero además de el
conflicto que se genera porque no
solamente le han cortado el
abastecimiento a trescientos veinte mil
y ciento cincuenta mil armenios en la
zona de nagono carabach en arzag sino
que además los han dejado incomunicados
han cortado las telecomunicaciones han
cortado internet es decir que en este
momento están totalmente aislados del
resto del mundo y sometidos a una
presión política enorme pero pero
también es importante entender esta
distracción del mundo con Ucrania no
está prestando relevancia a este a este
conflicto que es sumamente grave Porque
además incluye a Irán incluye la
expansión del imperio Turco en este
momento
imperio otomano bien un desafío a Rusia
que podría ser el siguiente paso luego
de la Guerra de Ucrania
y pasó ahora a darle la bienvenida a
nuestro otro invitado Fernando Gracias
por estar con nosotros también en su
punto de vista perspectiva de este
conflicto como Punto de partida de El
debate
Buenos días Santiago y justamente es una
cuestión bastante grave porque bueno
primero el principal porque no es la
primera vez que esto ocurre recordemos
que en el invierno del hemisferio norte
del 2021
el estado de Sevilla había cortado la
provisión de gas a la región de naborno
garapa estamos hablando de una región
que se encuentra a dos mil metros de
altura por lo tanto cortar la provisión
de gas no es un dato menor
justamente hoy por hoy el estado acerino
se encuentra digamos en una posición en
la cual quiera negociar precisamente
porque se encuentra en una posición de
fuerza luego de la victoria en la guerra
del 2020 y precisamente con Rusia
bastante digamos ocupada con la Guerra
de Ucrania entonces bueno precisamente
por eso no no tiene ningún interés en
negociar
[Música]
Así que ciertamente una cuestión muy
grave pero lamentablemente no es para
nada sorprendente lo que está ocurriendo
retomó la comunicación entonces con
Ignacio usted nos decía que tiene
algunos apuntes y conocimiento de Cuál
es la posición de azerbaiyán entonces
tratemos de entender Qué es lo que está
buscando azerbaiyán a través del bloqueo
de esta región de este corredor
importante qué es lo que buscan las
autoridades de bakú que hay que decir
también es un gobierno casi monárquico
lleva muchísimos años en el poder la
misma familia casi que desde antes de la
independencia de azerbaiyán en los años
90 y es un gobierno que se ve
beneficiado por las riquezas que le deja
la venta de gas y de petróleo a la
República de azerbaiyán
qué es lo que quiere bakú y qué es lo
que quiere ankara porque es imposible
analizar el papel sin entender qué es lo
que quiere ankara lo primero si
agarramos un mapa de azerbaiyán no vamos
a descubrir vamos a descubrir que son es
un país vivido en dos Sí vamos a ver
como curso tiene mucha importancia con
lo que sucede
es una parte que está en en el Oriente
que es la mayor parte y hay un enclave
que es el
las que van que es una parte que está
separada de la del resto de azerbaiyán
en el medio está
Armenia Entonces el reclamo que hace la
la el gobierno de bakú sobre la región
de nagorno caravag tiene mucho que ver
con lo que quiere conseguir para
conectar las dos partes de su territorio
es decir está sometiendo una serie al
adorno para negociar también con Armenia
el poder lograr un corredor en la zona
de sanga Sur que está en la zona Sur
para poder conectar las dos partes de su
país es decir el conflicto no es
solamente en esa región es un poco más
amplio y a su vez
que Turquía lo que quiere conseguir con
este apoyo azer es limita con este
enclave sí al oeste de de azerbaiyán
quiere hacer una línea de conexión que
le permita conectar con el resto de
azerbaiyán y a su vez le permitiría
sacar por el sur y ya no por suerte que
es al norte
las riquezas gasíferas y petrolíferas de
azerbaixán que para dar una idea de lo
que de lo que representan en el año 2023
planea exportar veinticuatro mil
millones de dólares de gas y la mitad de
esos van a Europa entonces para para
recapitular se trata de un conflicto
geográfico muy complejo muy estimulado
por y apoyado por por Turquía y con
intereses económicos muy poderosos que
tienen que ver con obviamente los no
solamente los negocios sino con la ropa
que le permite a Turquía ejercer esta
presión a través de las organizaciones
en contra de Armenia Ignacio muy puntual
por favor ya le doy la palabra Fernando
pero se justifica este bloqueo del
corredor de la chin por parte de
azerbaiyán que eso es lo que estamos
tratando de entender en este momento que
está bloqueado y se está aislando la
región y cómo se justifica esa acción de
ninguna manera porque los reclamos
ambientalistas vamos a ser sencillos si
si vos te haces un reclamo ambiental
pero al mismo tiempo estás bombardeando
una zona muy muy ecologista no son se
trata de presiones estratégicas
originadas en juegos de poder y juegos
económicos no no la posición a serie es
absolutamente insostenible insostenible
Fernando pasemos ahora a ver entonces La
otra cara de la moneda y es el lado
armenio Armenia anteriormente en un
conflicto en los 90 digamos que logró
triunfar a nivel territorial y logró
garantizar que este territorio
permaneciera sin reconocimiento
internacional pero se mantuviera
independiente lejos de ser gobernado por
azerbaiyán hoy en día la situación es
muy diferente el poderío militar de
azerbaiyán es muy distinto y recibe el
apoyo internacional de Turquía que tanto
margen de acción tiene Armenia en este
momento para poder defender a los
armenios que viven en esta zona que
reclamada por azerbaiyán
sí Armenia en realidad no tiene
demasiado margen de acción por varios
motivos como bien sabemos tanto Armenia
como la República no reconocida del
adornos garapac resultaron derrotadas
luego de la guerra del 2020 en la cual
ayer atacó en septiembre del 2020 No
solamente la región de la paz sino
Armenia misma
lo que quería acotar porque es muy
interesante lo que decís Ignacio con
relación a a la posición del gobierno
aserí estamos hablando de un de un
régimen dictatorial que dura ya dos
generaciones recordemos que primero está
el padre ahora está ahí lamaliev un
régimen el cual no no se tolera ningún
tipo de disensión ni de manifestación
y de repente aparecen supuestos digamos
militantes ecologistas
llevados por el mismo gobierno en los
buses en autobuses hasta esta región de
guerra en la cual los ciudadanos a
series tampoco tienen fácil fácil acceso
entonces resulta demasiado sospechoso
esta esta demuestra etiqueta de de
digamos de militantes
medioambientalistas si no aparece como
una herramienta más por parte del
gobierno aserid de intentar asfixiar un
poco más a lo armenios que viven en la
región de navarno carapaz para que de a
poco se vayan yendo Me parece muy
importante también remarcar que Rusia
que actúa supuestamente como garante de
la frágil tregua en la región no es en
realidad no es solo que no puede sino
posiblemente tampoco quiere intervenir
precisamente porque Rusia vende parte
del gas que no le puede vender Europa a
cervezan Parque cervellán se lo venda
también a Europa de forma legal es decir
la cerveza no solamente
el gas que que tienen su territorio sino
a su vez el gas que le vende Rusia
entonces una cuestión como
una cuestión muy complicada porque
implica digamos varios actores entre
ellos Turquía como bien había nombrado
él implica Rusia implica obviamente la
Unión Europea en un invierno en el cual
de repente se encuentra sin el gas ruso
en Fernando continuó con usted para
entender
la situación esta gente lleva un mes
bloqueada en esta región en condiciones
invernales difíciles todavía veíamos en
las declaraciones de el ministro de
estado de la región de abstage que hay
comida todavía muchas personas no han
podido regresar a Armenia o viceversa
personas que estaban en Armenia de
vacaciones no han podido regresar a
nagono caravag quedaron las familias
divididas pero aquí estamos hablando de
una estrategia de limpieza étnica
Exterminio o lo que buscan es que esta
gente abandone esta región cuál cree
usted que es la hipótesis más acertada
no sé ni en ninguna novedad en realidad
de ningún tipo de política digamos
a la fuerza o simplemente
invitándolos entre comillas a irse por
parte de azer porque esto ya ocurrió en
los años 90 recordemos que en bakú y en
principales ciudades de azervellán una
buena parte de la población eran
armenios armenios viviendo en la
cervellán es decir ciudadanos a series
de la República socialista soviética de
cervella que fueron básicamente
expulsados
y sea de un modo forzado sea de un modo
un poco más si lo que podemos si lo que
estamos viendo ahora lo podemos
considerar un poco soft no sería ninguna
sorpresa porque el estado se iba a
intentar todos los medios posibles de
digamos meter en adecuación de poner en
adecuación el discurso y el acto un
discurso abiertamente Al menos fóbico
que dice estas tierras las tenemos que
limpiar utilizo varias veces la palabra
perros
de los perros armenios Entonces se da de
una forma un poco más
soft O sea de la forma militar directa
no me parece tan sorprendente que esté
intentando expulsar a la población civil
Ignacio Quiero preguntarle quiero que
empecemos de arriba hacia abajo
entendiendo el papel que tiene la
comunidad internacional este tema ha
sido poco o no ha sido mencionado en los
medios internacionales no veo uno a los
líderes de las diferentes potencias
internacionales hablando sobre el tema
han hecho declaraciones muy vagas o
prácticamente nada países aliados de
Armenia por ejemplo como Francia o
Estados Unidos poco o nada han dicho
sobre el tema lo mismo del lado de
azerbaiyán poco o nada han dicho sus
países aliados Por qué a la comunidad
internacional este tema
le pasa por debajo de cuerda y no le
importa estas 120.000 personas que están
aisladas del mundo y que se exponen
alambre y al frío en las próximas
semanas
muy buena tu pregunta porque hable abre
un un espacio para hablar de de por qué
tiene que interesarle porque esto puede
ser un conflicto que explote hacia toda
la región pero sabes que mira se habla
mucho de la de la de lo poco de la
debilidad que tiene Armenia Armenia
tiene una una potencia que muy poca
gente conoce que tiene que ver con
justamente las etnias con las dias por
Armenia
poco saben que Armenia tiene más gente
viviendo el exterior que en su propio
país tiene son doce millones y hay tres
millones de Armenia
Y dónde está el resto el resto está en
Rusia ahí hay dos millones 250 hay un
millón ochocientos mil armenios en
Estados Unidos en Francia hay un millón
en Argentina desde donde estoy hablando
también tenemos una una enorme comunidad
de 135.000 y se van repartiendo en
varios países en donde el peso comercial
y político que tienen está empujando
para que este conflicto sea importante
Ahora lo más interesante de este
conflicto y que lo realmente lo empieza
a hacer internacional por esto estamos
hablando es que también los hace diez
tienen la mayor parte de su población
viviendo en el exterior con lo cual ya
empezamos a entender que este conflicto
no se no se limita a un marco geográfico
pequeño
saben dónde vive la mayor parte de los
aseríes en Irán
un Irán que hoy atraviesa una serie de
turbulencias políticas provocadas por la
rebelión de los de los velos y que tiene
la osaceríes entre los entre los pueblos
más pasivos entonces lo que empezamos a
ver
polencias no solamente influyen en
escenarios como el ruso como el
norteamericano sino que hacen presión
para ser importante pero también tiene
una derivación súper importante y es que
hablábamos del paso de una región a la
otra de de azer que está intentando
hacerla a través de Armenia Pero
sigue con turbulencias también lo puede
hacer A través de la zona habitada por
los aseríos en Irán Pero eso desataría
un conflicto con los perchas lo que lo
que yo lo que el punto al que quiero
llegar es porque este conflicto es menor
para la comunidad internacional Por qué
los armenios en adorno caravag tienen
tal parece un menor valor para la
comunidad internacional frente a los
ucranianos están en una situación claro
la escalada del conflicto es distinto
pero pero son personas que están en
riesgo no son menores o mayores la
importancia que pueda tener los armenios
en agono caravaca los rojillas que están
en bangladesh Y por qué la comunidad
internacional no reacciona además que
aquí si lo vemos en la perspectiva lo
que usted Ignacio Armenia está en
desventaja porque no hay Petro ligas de
por medio para ir a negociar en la
comunidad internacional como si lo tiene
bakú
Ignacio tiene un problema con su audio
vamos a retomar la comunicación Hay un
problema con el micrófono paso a darle
la palabra Fernando la misma pregunta
Fernando que también se la lleva a hacer
a usted porque la comunidad
internacional pone en una escala de
valores o poco más abajo a los armenios
y y le resta importancia a este
conflicto
yo creo simplemente que hay una cuestión
de Digamos como se dice en francés dos
kilos pero dos pesos diferentes es decir
yo mismo trabajo aquí en Francia con
migrantes que muchos de ellos vienen de
Afganistán muchos ellos vienen de países
del África subsahariana y de repente
muchos de ellos estaban bastante
choqueados al ver todas las ayudas que
se le daban a los inmigrantes ucranianos
lo cual está bien obviamente es decir
está bien se ayuda a los inmigrantes
ucranianos Pero estos mismos migrantes
decían y nosotros Qué es decir el hecho
que de repente por la cuestión
básicamente de conveniencia por por
parte de ciertos países centrales o de
ciertos bloques centrales en este caso
de Europa
digamos la situación humanitaria sea más
o visible o la la Perdón la crisis
humanitaria sea más visible en unos
países en otros y sí ciertamente implica
con una especie de doble moral lo en
términos éticos me parece gravísimo de
que del caso de yemen muy poca gente
habla
y hace años que la crisis humanitaria
continúa entonces en el caso de cerveza
me parece como bastante gráfico incluso
Yo te diría incluso me parece
pornográfico en sentido de que estamos
viendo los motivos por los cuales Europa
o la comunidad internacional no hace
gran cosa básicamente porque Europa le
compra gas a cervezan
y precisamente por eso no despierta
tanto tanto interés en cuestión de hecho
es la primera vez a través de que veo
que se habla de del tema en los en los
medios es decir que se le da cierta
importancia al tema de los medios hay un
hay un poderío económico recordemos que
azerbaiyán no solamente exporta este
tipo de productos y hidrocarburos y
derivados sino que también es sponsor o
patrocinador de importantes equipos de
fútbol de ligas europeas y allá hay un
peso económico también
por toda la industria que mueve el tema
del deporte en ese continente retomamos
ya la conexión entonces con Ignacio
también en la ciudad de Buenos Aires
para seguir conversando sobre este tema
le decía Ignacio entonces que vamos de
arriba hacia abajo ya hablamos de la
comunidad internacional de los
organismos internacionales aquí en
Naciones Unidas no ha dicho
absolutamente nada ha hecho un llamado a
desescalar la atención pero no ha hecho
nada por ir a ayudar a estos habitantes
la Cruz Roja sí que ha enviado algunas
ambulancias y algunos servicios de ayuda
que han logrado cruzar y romper este
bloqueo para entrar hasta nagono caravag
hablemos ahora de los actores
mencionábamos a Turquía a Rusia
profundicemos en el caso Turco en el
caso ruso la importancia que tiene y lee
la importancia que tiene para Rusia la
región del cáucaso y apoyar a Armenia
a ver hablemos de la hipocresía de las
razones de la hipocresía siempre tiene
que ver con los motivos geopolíticos y
económicos Sí hoy Turquía tiene
controlado y la comunidad occidental le
cedió el control a esa región a Turquía
Simplemente porque Turquía tiene a la
región de azer y Armenia como parte del
nodo que construye para abastecer de
energía de de del caucaso y también de
Rusia a Europa con lo cual este
conflicto es como un costo privado de de
Turquía y y si es así bueno la comunidad
occidental este va a ser hoy dos sordos
Por más que las comunidades internas
pidan Que que se le preste atención en
segundo lugar porque Rusia no interviene
Entonces no sirve a los fines debilitar
a Rusia y porque Armenia le pidió a
Rusia que saque sus tropas porque se dio
cuenta que es inútil como actor dentro
de la región ya no sirve Rusia como
mediador como hizo cuando intervino con
sus tropas En el anterior conflicto
Entonces dejó de ser una zona caliente
para hacer una zona controlada por
Turquía con enormes intereses occidente
para Occidente y que de alguna manera
también como decía al molestar a Irán es
utilitaria para todo este gran juego de
ajedrez que se que se que se ejecuta en
esta zona y por lo tanto no es
previsible que en funciones hipocresía
se preste atención a lo que está
sucediendo con los armenios en el
enclave Fernando y ahora analicemos el
tema de Turquía un país importante que
ha jugado aquí históricamente
diferentes roles en esa Región del
cáucaso entendamos el contexto de
Turquía tiene un brazo metido en el
conflicto en Siria Está tratando de ser
mediador en Ucrania Pero también es un
país que está a puertas de unas
elecciones presidenciales que son muy
importantes para el presidente erdogan
sobre todo por el tema económico porque
el país tiene una alta inflación y hay
muchos reclamos por parte de la
ciudadanía qué tanto le conviene a
Turquía seguir apoyando a azerbaiyán
seguir metiéndose en este conflicto de
esa manera sutil a través de el envío de
armas y drones al ejército de azerbaiyán
Turquía en términos civilizacionales y
en términos políticos siempre apostó a
al pantureanismo es decir a la unión de
todos los pueblos o mejor dicho todos
los estados y Por ende los pueblos de
habla turca
intentando generar una una continuidad
territorial y económica y desde hace un
tiempo militar desde Turquía hasta el
Asia central de su forma de proyectar
poder en digamos la región del cauca eso
Sur norte y del Asia central entonces
Turquía necesita seguir apoyando a hacer
bella porque básicamente es la
plataforma a través de la cual puede
proyectar poder para para con Europa y
para poder hacerle frente a Rusia
recordemos en realidad que es la guerra
lanzada por el presidente aseri en el
fue Por así decirlo permitida gracias a
la política exterior de erdogan en un
momento en el cual estaba digamos
bastante más agresivo de bueno de lo que
venía haciendo los últimos años
recordemos la encontronazos con chipre
lo encontronazos que tuvo con incluso
con el presidente de Francia macron
una política mucho más activa en contra
de los kurdos una política militar mucho
más activa en Siria y en Libia entonces
para Turquía le conviene seguir digamos
apostando le desestabilización de la
región Porque mientras más terreno gane
en términos políticos no solo
geográficos obviamente pero mientras más
terreno gane a servellán más terrena
está ganando el régimen de erdogan y
como bien estás diciendo
Turquía se encuentra en un momento muy
difícil en términos de inflación en
términos digamos de depreciación de la
de la lira turca entonces la carta fácil
del nacionalismo Turco es algo que
genera genera algún tipo de legitimación
Más allá de los réditos políticos y
económicos de mantener la guerra y
mantener el gas fluyendo desde el desde
el caspio Bueno vamos llegando ya al
bloque final del programa de este
análisis de la situación allí en el
corredor de la chin que une a nagorno
caravaco en Armenia qué podemos decir en
qué va a terminar esta historia estamos
en el inicio de otra de otro capítulo
más de un conflicto Esto va a estallar
Esto va a generar un desplazamiento
masivo de los habitantes de esta región
Fernando qué análisis hace usted de Cara
a el futuro de esta región
la cuestión es que es muy probable
Espero que no de corazón Espero que no
más allá del costado político por una
cuestión humana Espero que no pero la
cuestión es que todo parece llevar a
un o a un nuevo conflicto es decir
empujando para que hayan cada vez más
encontronazos y que pueda legitimar un
nuevo ataque o bien un desplazamiento
masivo de la población sin embargo no
hay que tampoco Para nada
subestimar la determinación de los
habitantes de la región Que bueno que
aguantaron dos guerras y que siguen
viviendo en esta misma región una
especie de resiliencia digamos muy
parecida por ejemplo a la del pueblo
palestino
[Música]
que ha decidido quedarse en el lugar
pero a mí me parece que el porvenir no
es demasiado
no es demasiado digamos no soy demasiado
optimista Lamentablemente la cuestión es
que mientras más Europa le deje hacer
Tanto erdogan como alier más van a
seguir tirando de la cuerda y esto es
grave y bueno espero verdaderamente
estar equivocándome en todo lo que estoy
diciendo por la cuestión humana
sí Y hasta ahora pues no no hay críticas
azerbaiyán por lo que está haciendo paso
a darle la palabra a Ignacio su
perspectiva de lo que pueda venir para
las próximas semanas para este conflicto
en medio del invierno con posibilidades
de desabastecimiento y hambrunas en los
próximos en las próximas semanas allí en
la región de nagorno caravaca yo lo veo
perspectivas de solución inmediata creo
que va a ser un conflicto crónico como
lo es hasta ahora no le veo solución
particularmente por la ansiedad que
tiene Europa de del gas proveniente del
cáucaso y también porque están
necesitando mucho a Turquía para frenar
a Rusia hacia el sur y para debilitarla
y por lo tanto Considero que se debe
prestar atención a este conflicto y creo
que va a ser uno más de los muchos que
se van a a desatar no solamente así sino
también por estar en Siria en el norte
de Irak con Turquía y en la medida que
Europa necesita tanto Turquía estos
conflictos van a seguir desarrollándose
o sea iba a llegar un momento en el que
Europa va a tener que sentarse a hablar
con el el nuevo gigante otomano que pesa
sus problemas económicos se sigue
expandiendo me quedaron un par de
minutos para preguntarles por un actor
importante acá y es el gobierno de
Armenia que ha tenido también muchos
problemas
ha sido muy criticado por los ciudadanos
hemos visto las manifestaciones en
yerbah en otras ciudades del país en
contra del Primer Ministro pachiñán cae
pachiñán este va a ser otro reto difícil
para él o continúa no hago la misma
pregunta del lado de azerbaiyán porque
entendemos que es un gobierno que está
atornillado en el poder desde hace
varias décadas y es muy distinta la
situación pero en Armenia en donde sí ha
habido revoluciones recientes para
cambiar el gobierno y forzar un cambio
en la política del país es muy probable
que pueda verse otras manifestaciones
Ignacio que los ciudadanos estén en
desacuerdo con la situación y la y las
medidas que tome Armenia sí lo que
sucede en Armenia Es que es que también
atraviesa una una crisis económica
también derivada de su inestabilidad
exterior que no le ayuda a resolver ni a
conseguir los recursos para hacerle
frente a cervellán con éxito y la
inestabilidad política no más allá de
los nombres propios es algo que tiene
que resolver Armenia si quiere tener
algún tipo de posibilidad para para
hacerle frente a los dilemas de Su
futuro y Fernando su opinión
sí
es interesante pensar que de algún modo
Rusia
castiga las distintas democracias del
espacio posoviético de forma directa o
indirecta cuando Ucrania o Georgia
intentaron algún tipo de movimiento
democratizante digamos que la reacción
rusa fue directa hubo un castigo directo
de forma militar tanto en George en el
2008 como en Ucrania a partir de 2014 el
movimiento democratizante o no
posiblemente más
como para limpiar las viejas oligarquías
soviética y posoviéticas que comenzó en
la revolución de de terciopelo del 2018
de algún modo también Fueron castigadas
indirectamente por Rusia al darle el
visto bueno a cervellán para la guerra
del 2020 Entonces sí ciertamente hay
varios movimientos de contestación
interna para con el Primer Ministro
paginan que sin embargo ganó una
elección luego de haber perdido la
guerra lo cual llama bastante la
atención pero
todos los observadores Internacionales
están de acuerdo en decir que fue que
fueron elecciones limpias pero a su vez
la oposición se encuentra en alguna
medida dividida porque como decía
Ignacio Más allá del gobierno de turno
hay una cuestión estructural
digamos de debilidad estructural estando
entre Turquía y Rusia
Que bueno que es mucho más difícil que
de resolver que que posiblemente no sea
simplemente con un cambio de gobierno de
cualquier manera los movimientos de
contestación existen
y el Primer Ministro passinian está en
alguna medida en posición bastante
bastante tanto para con su política
externa como en su política interna
insisto en el hecho de que ganó una
elección de forma limpia Pero de
cualquier manera la contestación está
permanentemente literalmente las calles
claro me queda un minuto para finalizar
el programa hacemos las conclusiones
entonces de este tema lo que nos deja el
análisis de este conflicto rápidamente
comienzo entonces con Fernando para
hacer la ronda la inversa su conclusión
muy puntual por favor
Honestamente creo que la comunidad
internacional tiene que reaccionar
porque para la población local bueno
digamos que lamentablemente no tiene
muchas vías de acción más allá de la
resistencia local de la resiliencia
pero a su vez Es triste constatar
también que Europa Unidos Rusia
simplemente les conviene dejar las cosas
tal como están el detrimento de la
población local Ignacio su conclusión
[Música]
por la cantidad de recursos y por las
alianzas creo que Armenia y los armenios
merecen un futuro tanto como los azerías
y si no hacemos algo me parece que
estamos cerrando y somos hipócritas Y
eso no está no está bien en ningún
escenario pues vamos a ver cuál va a ser
entonces la reacción de la comunidad
internacional y cómo responden estos
países que están involucrados directa o
indirectamente en este conflicto veremos
los hechos muy en detalle lo que vaya
ocurriendo a lo largo de esta semana San
Ignacio de Fernando les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros hoy En nombre
del equipo técnico les agradezco la
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera Muchas gracias
sigan con France 24
[Música]